hello and welcome to this video and just
one guitars Marquand and yep I can scam
it mm-hmm play the Catalan yeah ah sorry
so I'm trying some trying trying the the
Magnus lined with impact II fought
against alien off them almost just
playing just Bishop f4 like that
interesting okay switching back to c 6
p-6 then hmm or maybe this one and then
f5 if the night is on c3 I feel a little
bit more inclined towards playing with
f5 the knight on c3 is a little bit
further away from the e5 square so
usually you and sorry you don't mind the
stone board that much if you can in the
night is on c3
yeah I can't my pieces not completely
ideal for the stone wall so do I could
bishop t6 still and Queen to e7 things
like that hmm I don't know that it
doesn't help that much any other ideas I
can play g5 which is very hard very hard
ones but maybe
when I deist Bishop f6 to g7 maybe b3
okay that's not I don't think he wants
to Castle him that that I don't don't
believe okay let's push this and see
what is what is doing it it's very it's
very risky probably mmm this one yeah
there also was the return which wasn't
clear to me
that fits a bit shake here this position
seagoing f3 yeah again then that i can
probably take a Danite on h5 this is a
really silly looking piece ok thank you
it's got evil intentions it open the D
file so maybe I'm pre-empting this
maybeee form now don't don't think so I
wonder if Bishop my 82 g6 is doing any
good that might be an idea yeah not
anymore
quite shaky he went out of this default
situation and now it's probably
threatening to tick tick and play 9065
hmm
poor that's not good at all okay i need
you i need to somehow muddy the waters
him that has really the main ideas to
make it make it somewhat murky I should
play Bishop g5 maybe I was thinking
about the move earlier but I couldn't I
mean he a guy Kia it was too late but I
wanted to move earlier that would have
been an interesting move he just wants
to kill me in the center here
night xt5 is the thing that opens up the
the whole position but ok I take Bishop
takes Bishop c6 is that losing might be
start losing maybe Jay I can play Queen
d3 this this this move might be the
problem for Queen f5 Quincy 2 i'm sorry
and this this this move is the problem
Quincy too and my queen is hanging is
threatening Queen f5 as well Prince it
to us is killing I guess
Queen f5 since this is really ugly stuff
Crean age 7 king is 6 check
yeah it looked completely lost one
minute though this is always randomizing
thanks a little bit it's there are the
ideas some ideas at least come on the
soul kids do this tween f7 I don't know
I'm probably that is that is helping him
making things more yeah let's do this at
5i can take nya f5 I cannot I cannot
take you five I have what a bad game he
can go by five I have to pad out to play
king a queen f7f 52 spinster wins the
game check I of course check
what is the threat what isn't a threat
it's maybe the easier question GreenEDGE
for I'm just continuing because there
are some vague ideas like night f4 maybe
for the bishop 16 still still there ok
check
Jeff any tricks late night coming up
here check check check okay come on
let's useless anyway that resides ah and
that was I was was a very ambitious wait
for playing it with g5g phone I don't
think it's so bad I just have to play
more precisely after that it's risky
it's clearly risky Bishop d7 rookie one
that's very good I think yeah and now
Luke c82 looks okay champ and around
here I think it gets it becomes very
shaky maybe I should have played Bishop
g5 somewhere around here but I never got
to do that ninety-seven is an
improvement this is pretty I think
pretty key as an improvement
the computer wants to do this it gives
it doesn't give wide such a clear
advantage surprisingly I think that that
looks pretty terrible something like
this yeah it looks pretty awful Tim May
this is a bit too risky and they have to
improve may be here chef d 7 looks
normal though property one yeah not not
quite sure it's at least easier to play
for why therefore was really just ok
let's let's do something crazy to make
things more complicated but he can do
that he just can giant Quincy to us is
winning so this has the only move to at
least continue a little bit and T I have
to go Queen f7 to ya to prolong the game
but after 23 he's got this mess it's
losing it's just lost position check
check if I'd that wasn't strictly
necessary but it's a pretty good I
thought each King because he can just go
there I have no mercy as well with Chad
before was a very clean solution yeah
yeah it looked like a really good game
by white I don't see any great way to
improve this is maybe am oops a little
bit too demanding what's it for the
black side maybe I should go here and
just just just just go for that I don't
think um this is so much of a strategic
problem that these pieces are traded for
example let's say he does that
I'll take oops take and here i don't
think that this is so terribly bad it
looks bad as the points on light squares
and so on but that bishop is also not
doing that much for example what the
engine gives the engine and wants to go
F form and gives white almost one pawn
I'm not positive about that I mean of
course you have to give white an
advantage but I'm not sure that is such
a serious one it's very difficult for y2
to get anything substantially if I just
play like here rook c8 night back in the
age porn it's rather dry and I'd rather
Drive that's wrong but the position is
is so close that it is not ki m that the
bishop on OMG one is such a superior
piece so I'm not I'm not totally
convinced that this is totally rotten
for black I don't like it but I don't
think it's lost or anything like that
okay well thanks for watching